Çeviri: Nihal Aksakal
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Merhabalar.
Ahmet Orhon ben.
Bu konuşmanın sonunda, her birimizin
birer tane Eyfel Kulesi olacak.
Her birimizin, çok güzel,
birer Eyfel Kulesi olacak.
Işıl ışıl, birer Eyfel Kulemiz olacak.
Anlatacağım size, nasıl her birimizin
birer Eyfel Kulesi olabileceğini
ama bunu anlatabilmem için
en başa dönmemiz gerekiyor.
Ankara ayazının zirve yaptığı
bir ocak ayında doğmuşum ben.
Doğumumdan önce doktorlar
zihinsel engelli olabileceğimi
söylemişler aileme.
Haliyle bizimkiler tedirgin,
kaygılı bir hamilelik dönemi geçirmiş.
Sonunda doğmuşum hem de
tam 5 kiloluk bir çocuk
olarak doğmuşum ama
3 yaşıma kadar ağzımı dahi açmamışım.
Zihinsel engelli olmadığımı anlamışlar,
ama çokta parlak bir
çocuk olmayacağıma kanaat getirmişler.
Sonra 4 yaşlarında beni abimin
fizik kitabını okurken bulmuşlar.
Nasıl okuma yazma öğrendiği
bilinmeyen bir çocuk.
Harfler, rakamlar bir şekilde
DNAlarına işlenmiş bir çocuk.
Büyük şehirlerin kenar mahallelerinde
yaşayanlarınız var mı bilmiyorum
ama bu tip yerlerde bu tip
güzel haberler, bu tip küçük mucizeler
çok hızlı yayılırlar.
Benim de namım öyle yayılmış mahallede.
Ankara, Siteler, Hacılar Mahallesi'nde
benim de namım öyle yayılmış.
Mahallede bir çocuk var, kendi kendine
okuma yazma öğrenmiş.
Bir çocuk var, üç beş basamaklı
sayıları aklından çarpabiliyor.
Bir çocuk var, bir okuduğunu
bir daha unutmuyor.
Mahallede küçük bir dahi var.
Bakkala gidiyorum ekmek almaya,
kalın gözlüklerinden dolayı
Kör Durmuş lakabını almış amca
'Mehmet'in oğlu, sen şu çikolatayı al, sen
okuyacaksın, sen büyük adam olacaksın.'
diyor, bir çikolatayı bana veriyor.
Sokakta yürüyorum,6 kişilik ailesi için
3-4 tane portakalı anca alabilen
Yurdagül Teyze hiç tereddüt etmeden
o portakallardan birini bana uzatıyor
'Oğlum, sen bunu ye, aklına
vitamin olsun.' diyor.
Kenar mahalleleri bir düşünün,
bir kaosunu düşünün,
hareketliliğini, gürültüsünü bir düşünün.
Ben ders çalışıyorum
ve 45. Sokakta çıt dahi çıkmıyor.
İlkokula da fırtına gibi başladım.
İlkokul birinci sınıfı atladım.
Girdiğim sınavlardan tam not alıyordum,
özellikle matematikte inanılmaz hızlıydım.
Ama bir durum vardı.
Sınıfta en az benim kadar iyi,
en az benim kadar hızlı,
en az benim kadar zeki, başarılı
birisi daha vardı.
İsmi Serap.
Saçları, at kuyruğu ile arkadan bağlanmış,
yüzünde hep kocaman
gülümsemesi olan Serap.
Şaşırdım tabi haliyle.
Hani ben küçük dahiydim,
mahallenin özel çocuğuydum?
En az ben kadar iyi Serap,
en az ben kadar akıllı,
en az ben kadar hızlı.
O günden sonra girdiğim bütün sınavlarda,
yaptığım bütün testlerde,
yaptığım bütün ödevlerde,
aklımda tek bir soru vardı.
Acaba Serap'tan iyi yaptım mı?
Bir ben, bir Serap derken
ilkokul bitti.
İlkokulun sonunda o zamanlar
Anadolu Lisesi sınavları vardı.
Yüz binlerce çocuğun,
hayatla tanışma merasimi adeta.
Özellikle maddi durumu çok iyi
bir aileden gelmiyorsanız,
bu sınav sizin yegane şansınızdı,
bu sınavda iyi yaparsanız
imkanları iyi bir okula gidebilirdiniz,
yapamadığınız takdirde ise
ne yazık ki ülkenin gerçeği
imkanları kısıtlı bir okula giderdiniz
ve kısıtlı imkanlarla
bir yerlere gelmeye çalışırdınız.
Ben de girdim bu sınava,
sınavda çok iyi yaptığımdan,
Ankara'nın en iyi okullarından birine
yerleşeceğimden adım gibi emindim.
Ama bir tek soru vardı aklımda.
Acaba Serap'tan iyi yaptım mı?
Yine büyük şehirlerin
kenar mahallelerinde oturanlar bilirler
yaz tatili demek köye gitmek
demektir bizim oralarda.
Seraplar köylerine gitmişti,
biz şehirde kalmıştık.
Bütün yaz arkadaşlarımla
vakit geçiriyorum,
sokakta top oynuyorum, bisiklete biniyorum
saklambaç oynuyoruz.
Ama aklımda tek bir soru var.
Acaba sınavda Serap'tan iyi yaptım mı?
Sonunda bir temmuz günü,
yine 45.sokağın köşesinde,
uzakta Serap'ı gördüm,
koşarak yanına gittim.
Beni görünce, o güzel gülümsemesi,
büyük gülümsemesi yine belirdi yüzünde.
''Serap! Serap!
Sınavın nasıl geçti?'' dedim.
''Ahmet ben sınava giremedim.'' dedi.
''Neden sınava giremedin?'' dedim.
Algılayamamıştım, anlamadım.
''Neden sınava girmedin?'' dedim.
''Babam benim sınava
girmemi istemiyor.'' dedi.
''Babam benim okumamı istemiyor.
Babam, benim onun arkadaşlarından
biriyle evlenmemi istiyor.'' dedi.
Daha yaşımız on ikiydi.
Ağlamaya başladı.
Ağlamaya başladım.
''Bana yardım et.'' dedi.
Ağzımdan tek kelime dahi çıkmadı,
çıkamadı, koşarak uzaklaştım.
Serap artık okumayacaktı.
Serap artık okula gitmeyecekti.
Anadolu Lisesi sınavlarını kazandım,
Fen Lisesi sınavlarını kazandım.
Üniversite sınavında derece yaptım.
Dünyanın en iyi şirketlerinden
birinde işe girdim.
Harvard'da yüksek lisans yaptım.
Küçükken sobanın yanında baktığım
atlasta hayal dahi edemeyeceğim
ülkelere gittim.
Tam 107 ülke gezdim.
Ama aklımda hep aynı düşünce vardı.
Serap burada olmayı, bu güzellikleri
yaşamayı en az benim kadar hak ediyordu.
Serap bugün burada bizlerle olmayı,
en az benim kadar hak ediyordu.
Serap gibi milyonlarca çocuk,
Serap gibi milyonlarca insan
bizlerle olmayı hak ediyor,
bizlerle bugün burada olmayı hak ediyor.
Bizlerin yaşadığı o güzel yaşantıyı
yaşamayı hak ediyorlar.
Ancak ne yazık ki hayat onlara,
bizlere davrandığı kadar
cömert davranmıyor.
Hayat herkese yeteri kadar
adil davranmıyor.
Peki biz ne yapıyoruz
bu konuyla ilgili?
Biz ne yapıyoruz
o çocuklar için, o insanlar için?
İnsanlık tarihinin en başından bu yana,
biz hep birlikte var olarak var olduk,
hep birlikte olarak
bu zorlukların üstesinden geldik,
üzüntülerimizi azalttık,
mutluluklarımızı arttırdık,
hep birlikte olarak var olduk biz.
Ama bu modern hayat,
sosyal medya, bu ışıltılı hayat,
bize biz olmamız gerektiğini unutturdu,
ben odaklı bir hayat yaşatmaya başladı.
Benim için bu işin içerisinde ne gibi
bir fayda var diye sormaya başladık,
ben nasıl mutlu olabilirim
diye sormaya başladık.
Biz annelerimize, babalarımıza,
abilerimize, kardeşlerimize
sarılmayı unuttuk,
biz yakın dostlarımıza,
arkadaşlarımıza sarılmayı unuttuk,
onlara sarıldıkça,
dertlerimizin azalacağını,
üzüntülerimizin azalacağını,
onlara sarıldıkça
mutluluklarımızın artacağını unuttuk.
Biz ya hep beraber var olacağımızı
ya da teker teker yok olacağımızı unuttuk.
İşte bu yüzden,
hiç olmadığı kadar mutsuzuz,
hiç olmadığı kadar
boşlukta hissediyoruz kendimizi,
hiç olmadığı kadar hayat
zor geliyor bize.
Şimdi dedim ya, ya hep beraber var
olacağız ya da teker teker
yok olacağız diye,
bunu hatırlamak için birer
Eyfel Kulesi yapacağız sizinle.
Her birimiz birer
Eyfel Kulesi inşa edecek
ve bu Eyfel Kulesi
insan yüzlerinden oluşacak
ve harcı da, o Eyfel Kulesi'ne
katacağınız harçta,
o insanların ümitlerinden,
hayallerinden oluşacak.
Sizlerden ricam şimdi
gözlerinizi kapatmanız.
Hepiniz lütfen gözlerinizi kapatın.
Annenizin babanızın yüzünü düşünün şimdi.
Onların hayallerini, ümitlerini düşünün.
Sabah beşe kadar derdinizi
dinleyen dostunuzu düşünün şimdi.
Onun da yüzünü koyun oraya,
onunda yüzünü koyun o Eyfel Kulesi'ne.
Diğer arkadaşlarınızı düşünün,
onların da hayallerinin, ümitlerinin
harcını katın Eyfel Kulesi'ne.
Hayatlarına dokunduğunuz
diğer insanları düşünün.
Mahallenizdeki manavı,
sokağınızdaki bakkalı düşünün.
İş arkadaşlarınızı düşünün,
okul arkadaşlarınızı düşünün,
onların yüzleri gelsin gözünüzün önüne
ve koyun Eyfel Kulesi'nin üstüne.
Onların hayallerini, ümitlerini
düşünün şimdi ve onlardan da katın
Eyfel Kulesi'nin harcının içerisine.
Sonra, sokakta, köşede
mendil satan çocuğu düşünün,
onun hayallerini düşünün,
onun hemen yanında
trafik polisi var.
Onu da düşünün, onun da
yüzü gelsin gözünüzün önüne
ve onu da koyun Eyfel Kulesi'ne
ve onların da hayallerini düşünün.
Her gün bindiğiniz
metrobüsteki şoförün de yüzünü düşünün,
o metrobüste koltuk yarışı
yaptığınız yaşlı teyzenin
yüzünü de düşünün, onun da hayallerini,
onun da ümitlerini düşünün.
Onların da yüzlerini koyun
Eyfel Kulesi'ne,
onların ümitlerinden
harç yapıp katın Eyfel Kulenize.
Hayatlarına dokunduğunuz
diğer insanları düşünün.
Şimdi gözlerinizi açın.
Biliyorum Eyfel Kulenizin inşaatı bitmedi.
Biliyorum, daha koymak
istediğiniz yüzler var.
Onların ümitlerini, hayallerini
yeteri kadar düşünecek
belki de vaktiniz olmadı.
Ama sizlerden ricam, bugün
buradan çıktıktan sonra,
her karşılaştığınız insanlar,
hayatına dokunduğunuz her insanla,
o insanın yüzünü almanız
ve Eyfel Kulesi'ne eklemeniz.
O Eyfel Kulesi'ne onların hayallerini,
onların ümitlerini eklemeniz.
Neden Eyfel Kulesi diyorum?
Eyfel Kulesi'nin iki tane özelliği vardır.
Birincisi, Eyfel Kulesi Paris'te
yol göstericilik için kullanılır.
İnsanlar adreslerini
ona göre tarif ederler.
İkincisi, Eyfel Kulesi ışıl ışıldır,
ona doğru yürümesi ayrı bir zevklidir.
Size de dedim ya, ya hep beraber
var olacağız ya da teker teker
yok olacağız ,
bunu hatırlatacak Eyfel Kulemizin
inşaatını da yaptık ya şimdi sizlerle,
arada bir hayat meşguliyetinden
dolayı her gün bakamasanızda,
arada bir geri adım atın
ve Eyfel Kulenize doğru
yürüdüğünüzden emin olun.
Hayatlarına girdiğiniz insanların
ümitlerine, hayallerine
katkıda bulunacak,
onların hayatlarında
bir farklılık yaratacak adımlar
attığınızdan emin olun,
doğru istikamete
gittiğinizden emin olun.
Belki o istikamete varamayacaksınız
belki Eyfel Kulenize
hiçbir zaman varamayacaksınız.
Ama ne dedik,
Eyfel Kulesi'ne doğru
yürümesi de çok güzel,
o ışıl ışıl kuleye doğru
yürümesi de çok güzel.
Hepinize iyi yolculuklar.
Teşekkürler.